you are a maverick you're a man who
doesn't believe it no i'm not a maverick
i
i think it's an art and you you get to
the edge but you don't fall after your
precipice and you stay within
the conventions of the system but you
push the system in the direction that it
should be going
and what i think is very important is to
push the system into a more
representative
direction to say that that little girl
there or that little girl there or
this little girl here made a choice on
being poor
i think begs the question to the point
of being ridiculous
anybody who says it can't be done really
doesn't have
the will the people must know the full
story of what has occurred over the past
20 years within their government
human beings are being killed
as i speak to you tonight killed as a
direct result of
policy decisions we as a body
have made it's like going into the
senate you know the first time you get
there you're all excited my god how did
i ever get here
then about six months later you say how
the hell did the rest of them get here
and i gotta tell you after standing up
with them some of these people frighten
me
they frighten me when you have mainline
candidates to turn around and say that
there's nothing off the table with
respect iran
that's code for using nukes nuclear
devices
arms arms are being
servered metal is crashing through human
bodies
[Music]
because of a public policy
this government
[Music]
first off understand that this war was
lost
the day that george bush invaded
iraq on a fraudulent basis george bush
communicated over a year ago
that he would not get out of iraq until
he left office
do we not believe him you pass the law
not a resolution
a law making it a felony to stay there
and i'll give you the text of it and let
the american people see
clearly who's keeping the war going and
who's not
and that's just the beginning of the
tactic if they're tough enough to do it
and i thought it was important to stand
up there and show people what i
am and what i stand for i believe in
people
in fact for this direct democracy
it's unreserved faith in the people
we've got a team
that's going to go forward that is just
awesome
and whether i'm around or not is is
beside the point
they could pull off direct democracy
all they're trying to do is to convey
one simple message
here's an ordinary citizen called mike
revell
and what he's doing he's trying to make
a change in society and then he's going
on
with his life or to death who knows and
if
some talking heads don't have enough
artistry
in their hearts to understand what these
kids were doing
that's their problem he is the author of
this footage this is his own campaign ad
why would any presidential candidate
produce a video that is this strange
throwing a rock in the water was a
metaphor for causing ripples and changes
in society
and then walking down and disappearing
isn't that what life's about
[Music]
[Music]
you